clickbait thumbnails trigger warnings oh
my
welcome back to my channel here folks if
you're watching this video you are
either a hardcore fan or you're a troll
or you're kind of both honestly trolls
if you think my team doesn't see you
racing to the comment section within the
first 15 minutes every single time I
post Justice spew vitriol you're lying
to yourself we see you and we think
you're very special members of the
Abby's kitchen Community thanks for the
ad rev but anyways today I'm going to be
addressing some of the criticism I
sometimes get about my clickbait titles
and thumbnails along with a really
important chat about trigger warnings so
let's start there actually so my husband
doesn't really watch my content but when
he has his only commentary is something
like oh my God it must be so exhausting
to have to have all these trigger
warnings and content notes and
preemptive disclaimers about words that
you're saying or not saying before you
can actually get into what it is that
you need to talk about like why is
everybody so sensitive and honestly I've
always just kind of ignored his comments
because I was like ah yeah typical man
dismissing the lived experience and
Trauma of so many women who've entrusted
me in their safe care then more recently
maybe like a year or so ago I was
talking to my younger sister and my
sister is a clinical psychologist and
she told me that trigger warnings on
media content may actually do more harm
than good and again at the time I was
like well yeah maybe that's true for
your content or your audience but my
peeps need these trigger warnings like
there's so much toxic content out there
in line as the Wild West out
there and I need to protect people but
then I was on vacation this summer
trying to like fake vacation as we do
and this article popped up on my Apple
news feed and I was like oh have I
actually caused more harm by trying so
hard to keep you know everybody happy
and safe I'm Gonna Leave a link to the
article below though it does have a
paywall but in short this op-ed draws on
recent research suggesting that trigger
warnings have actually little or no
benefit in cushioning the blow of
disturbing content and in some cases
they may actually be harmful for
survivors of trauma basically of the
researchers found that trigger warnings
increase the extent to which people see
trauma essential to their identity which
can be counter therapeutic because it
encourages avoidance and exacerbates
fear the researchers said that trigger
warnings are one of many examples of
ways that we over emphasize how
important trauma should be in our lives
and that this prevents us from moving
onwards and upwards there's also a whole
other meta-analysis looking at trigger
warning outcomes that have found that
presenting a trigger warning had
actually no effect on emotional response
to negative materials but in a lot of
cases it increased anticipatory anxiety
about the incoming content like people
get their guard up and it's like they're
triggered before they've even consumed
the content that might trigger them it
also found that the warnings either made
people want to read the content more or
it had no effect at all generally
speaking though it seemed clear that
trigger warnings aren't actually great
so I called them my sister again and
what she said really spoke to me she
said that basically today day it's kind
of a bit of a landmine to explicitly say
that you don't like or you don't use
trigger warnings because then you seem
really non-progressive which is probably
why I've kept them in rotation for so
long because as you guys know I'm a
sensitive person so I really try to
treat others with sensitivity as well
but my sister basically said that
trigger warnings were encountered to
everything we know about improving
mental health because the more that we
avoid something because of a past memory
of it being scary or bad then the more
scary that memory becomes it basically
adds fuel to the fire it also teaches us
that we're weak and fragile or incapable
of coping or growing you know there was
actually a comment on my recent video
about my UK trip which got me thinking
about this all over again and this
person said that people with EDS don't
have the impulse control when it comes
to weight loss content and that may be
true for some but it also got me
thinking why are we by default thinking
that folks who have struggled with their
mental health are incapable or weak why
are we automatically taking away
people's agency by saying no no no no no
I know people like you you can't handle
anything that's scary or hard because
when people hear that they think that's
true now I will just say that of course
if you're in the active throes of an ed
then discuss with your team on whether
or not you should be consuming online
content at all never mind nutrition or
Wellness content but eventually we come
out of active treatment and we need to
face the world and let's be honest the
whole world talks about weight loss
right it pops up on your for you page
it's at the magazines at the checkout
your relatives talk about it at the
dinner table like sure you could leave
the store every time you saw a magazine
with the words keto on the front page
and you could hide in the bathroom every
single time you're at a family gathering
but that doesn't support ongoing
recovery we need to eventually build
skills to face this world with
confidence so this is where I bring all
of you guys in like we've got options
right I continue adding trigger warnings
to all my videos so for any mention of
weight body food nutrition tips
everything I can not have trigger
warnings for anything and people can
listen to my introduction at the start
of the video to see what we're going to
be talking about and then you know of
course assume that there will be some
nutrition or Diet talk in most of my
videos or I can be selective where
perhaps I don't share trigger warnings
for most things like diet food nutrition
tips weight loss or weight gain but
maybe just for more sensitive
discussions like if there are explicit
Pro Ed tips at creators sharing or if
I'm sharing specific weight or
measurements the pause this video right
now and let me know in the comments
where if anywhere you think I should
draw the line so that's trigger warnings
now I want to talk about click bait this
is such a Hot Topic in my content
creator circles and it's something that
a lot of us get criticism for or
struggle with what to do so clickbait is
a controversial marketing tactic because
its job is to entice someone to click
and watch or read the content but when
the content itself is like a complete
mismatch with the title people feel
misled or like they wasted their time so
for example if the title of a magazine
article said how to lose 20 pounds in 20
days but the journalists actually just
ended up talking about intermittent
fasting where one random person happened
to lose 20 pounds in 20 days but all the
experts they interviewed said no you
can't lose 20 pounds in 20 days yeah
people will be disappointed because they
didn't find out how to lose a pound a
day it's also often criticized for
spreading myths or disinformation
because people will often just read the
article title and not the rest of the
article and again often the title lacks
contacts or Nuance or the whole truth so
an article titled berberine works better
than chemo could automatically lead
people to stop their chemo to buy
berberine without reading an article
that would obviously suggest that
berberine is not better than chemo
unless it's from like a BS blog in which
case it's the wild west so here's the
deal with my click bait yes my team and
I use the psychology apology of
clickbait when crafting our titles
clickbait psychology suggests that our
brains are primed for confirmation bias
and simplicity there are literally
millions of pieces of content flying at
us every day our brains will
automatically stop and pick up the
pieces that are instantly recognizable
uncomplicated and relatable the video
itself is for the context and the
complicated details the title has to be
Snappy it has to deliver a quick message
that hints towards the content within
but also be emotion driven and human
because you're human and I am human and
this is how we connect now as an example
I got a lot of criticism about my video
title on my UK Vlog which was originally
did I lose too much weight food and diet
while traveling abroad some people
criticize this title for being click
bait and while it may be clicky and it
may be baby I don't see it as being
dishonest or the spreading of
misinformation Vlogs are generally A bit
chaotic so I talk about a lot of things
in this one but one of the central
themes for me in this video that I felt
would be most useful for my audience was
about how to deal with unintentional
weight loss I could have also titled
this like I saw a ghost because I have a
little section where I talk about ghosts
I gotta call this London shopping hall
because a little fashion moment in there
but for me this weight loss angle was
what I felt would be most useful for my
audience and if I baited in my followers
with even disorder histories then great
they would be taking away a supportive
message that they really need that
weight loss shouldn't always be
celebrated and that it's sometimes an
act of self-care to eat more and try to
gain weight and that is what I try to do
with my titles and content I hope that
people realize that it's really hard to
compete with sensationalized diet
culture when one Creator posts a video
called this supplement will make you
lose 10 pounds today and I post a video
called this element may help support
weight loss when taken four times a day
in conjunction with a balanced diet and
exercise regimen which are people going
to click on the latter may be full of
misinformation whereas at least my video
will deliver the facts but no one is
going to learn those facts if they don't
click we've actually beta tested so many
video titles and found that if we want
my supportive science driven message to
get to the people who actually need it
you Gotta Fight Fire with Fire you need
to build Snappy emotion-driven simple
titles and that means you leave the
context to the video itself that said
I'm still truthful in my titles so for
example I will ask questions rather than
make absolute statements and my title
still reflects the content within I get
that people are still mad when you click
on a title thinking oh she's finally
going to give us some magic bullet for
weight loss and here I am sharing the
like not so sexy science again but these
are typically the kind of people who
need the cold hard truth that most
Wellness culture content is BS the
bottom line is that if we as a community
want to share science not pseudo science
as broadly as we can to the people who
need to hear it the most we need to play
ball like I'm up against 20 pounds in 20
days kind of so just just work with me
on this finally let's talk thumbnails so
I got some Flack for my thumbnails
particularly if I share images of bodies
or again anything that might be
triggering again the original thumbnail
of my UK Vlog is a really good example
on it I wrote I'm triggered and I had an
image of myself looking kind of
distraught and people in the comments
were suggesting that me saying I'm
triggered was making people triggered so
I changed it to this scared me even
though honestly I was triggered as with
the bodies this is super interesting
because my team and I talk about this
literally every week on our calls I
don't really show body check images of
myself anywhere online so my thumbnails
won't contain images of me personally
posing in a bikini or bra obviously no
shame to other creators who do this but
my body is just not really my business
card that said look at the wellness
landscape like even the most anti-diet
diet culture creators build their
thumbnails around their bodies why
because we live in a culture up obsessed
with small fit bodies and we see these
bodies and we want to learn from the
people behind them obviously and in a
lot of cases this is not a bad thing
like Natasha for example great content
great evidence-based advice I love her
so no judgment from me to other content
creators who use this tactic like gold
Glen Coco like show off that bod you
know just not my style so even though I
might not share my own body when I'm
doing the response video I often utilize
the same body check imagery that they
use to bait people in the first place
because again we sometimes need to Fight
Fire with Fire And if the original
content is problematic then I need to
attract the same vulnerable audience who
most needs my safe science-minded
interpretation and rebuttal obviously in
a perfect world a hot body wouldn't be a
greater indicator of clout than
education and expertise but this is the
world that we live in right now folks
and my team and I have beta tested this
so many times videos without a hot body
in the thumbnail tank videos with a hot
body get clicks welcome to diet culture
one-on-one I am not going to be able to
single-handedly change the game and at
the end of the day folks the people who
are easily influenced by clickbait
titles and body checks on thumbnails are
typically the ones who can benefit from
my content the most and maybe just maybe
it will attract someone on the brink of
change who will see my content and have
something click where they realize holy
this whole dye culture thing is not
serving me and even if it's just that
one person who gets that aha moment that
Sparks their healing journey I think
it's kind of worth annoying a few people
because they were hoping for more diet
culture and instead they got womp womp
critique of diet culture and that was a
lot
I would love to hear your thoughts on
this conversation I know this is going
to get a little spicy so please let's
keep it respectful and remember if
you're a VIP troll I'm watching you
everybody's watching you don't think
your obsession here doesn't go unnoticed
but on that note that is all for today
if you like this video be sure to give
it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below and I'll see you next time on
Abby's kitchen bye